la préparation
la concentration
l'effort
l'adrénaline tous les ingrédients d'une
compétition sportive était de retour au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines vingt mois après l'organisation
de la dernière course cycliste de la
structure le septième grand prix de
vélizy s'est déroulée ce dimanche 5
décembre va mois c'est très long et en
plus on sent qu il y à une
démobilisation des bénévoles des équipes
d'organisation donc il faut remettre
tout ça en ordre de marche il faut re
motiver donc tout toutes les équipes
donc on y arrive et j'espère que l'on va
continuer voilà sur cette lancée pour
continuer sur cette lancée organiser
deux nouvelles courses le vélodrome
nationale est suspendu à une décision
celle de retransformer ou non leurs
centrales en méga centres de vaccination
comme cela l'a été de mars à fin octobre
aujourd'hui les injections se font dans
les coursives de la structure on
travaille en osmose avec l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines pour
trouver les solutions qui conviennent à
tous
et qui permettent de maintenir
voilà la vaccination parce que ça on
comprend que c'est important et il faut
le faire mais tout en conservant les
activités habituelles du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
si l'avenir est incertain pour les
rendez vous sportifs dans la structure
les 150 coureurs présents ce jour là
n'ont pas boudé leur plaisir ça fait
forcément du bien de refaire des mages
de vitesse des sprints ouais j'attendais
ça
avec impatience donc reprendre par une
compétition à domicile ça fait toujours
du bien c'est quand même cool de pouvoir
retrouver des marques sur la compétition
pouvoir retrouver un
quelques amis et puis se confronter pour
voir où on en est au niveau tant au
niveau performance ça permet aussi de
mieux progresser les prochaines
manifestations cyclistes sont pour le
moment programmé en janvier février si
la situation sanitaire le permet